let's talk about the first one here cash
in on viral trends so today there's a
lot of trends there's website they can
go and say trending topics and you can
always figure out a way to you know cash
in on that Jessica she bakes cookies on
the side and one the story she was
telling me that got picked up on media
all over the place was she you know
these fidget spinners that are very hot
another's my kids have two of them I was
in LA the other day my niece and nephew
were talking about how they're trading a
gold one for green one and all this
other stuff Jessica made fidget spinner
cookie and all she did is make a video
and she took a bite after was done
spinning and suddenly goes viral who
picks it up by the way all these how
much traffic did I bring you how much
attention did that bring to your brand
so now think about it now this fidget
spinners may not work a year from now
but it works today because it's
everywhere right cashing on current
trends there's plenty of ways of doing
it